[Music]  after years of stepping out solo to the  star-studded events Ashton Kutcher and  Neela Kunis made their first joint red  carpet appearance since that 70 show and  they are relationship goals  laughing grinning and gazing into each  other's eyes the couple looked happier  than ever posing together for photos and  we're still in love  Ashton and Mila presented at the 6th  annual breakthrough prize ceremony on  Sunday the event brought together stars  of the screen stage and sport to  celebrate science although the lovebirds  have been married for two years and  share two kids one year-old son dmitri  and three-year-old daughter Wyatt the  event marks their first red carpet  together as a couple since expanding  their family the bad mom's actress has  been candid with et about balancing work  and motherhood it does change you know  working full time my husband moved his  company here so he works full-time I  work full-time we needed